FOR A PERIOD OF APPROXIMATELY
TEN MINUTES.
>> STUNNING TESTIMONY FROM TWO
FORMER TOP OFFICIALS OF THE
DONALD TRUMP JUSTICE DEPARTMENT,
TALKING ABOUT THE ROLE THAT THE
PRESIDENT, A MEMBER OF CONGRESS,
AND A JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL NAMED JEFFREY CLARK
PLAYED IN TRYING TO CONCOCT THE
SCHEME TO STEAL THE ELECTION
FROM THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE TESTIMONY CAME, I THINK IT'S
WORTH POINTING OUT, FROM THE
ACTING ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFFREY
ROSEN, AND THE ACTING DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL, RICHARD
DONAHUE.
BOTH OF THEM FORMER, OF COURSE.
WHO WERE INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE
LOYAL TO DONALD TRUMP.
THESE WERE TOP DONALD TRUMP
JUSTICE OFFICIALS.
YET THEIR ALLEGIANCE TO THE
CONSTITUTION AND THE FACTS OF
WHAT HAPPENED IN THE 2020
ELECTION OVERRODE THAT LOYALTY
TO PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THEY DID NOT CRITICIZE DONALD
TRUMP AT ALL PERSONALLY, DANA
BASH.
THEY DID NOT SAY ANYTHING
NEGATIVE ABOUT HIM.
THEY JUST DESCRIBED HIS
BEHAVIOR.
I DON'T KNOW THAT ANY OF THE
PEOPLE TWO BELIEVE THESE
ELECTION LIES ARE WATCHING OR
LISTENING, BUT IT WAS REALLY
QUITE JARRING TESTIMONY.
>> IT WAS.
AND THE WAY THAT THEY DESCRIBE
IT, ESPECIALLY RICHARD DONAHUE
DESCRIBED THE BACK AND FORTH
THAT HE HAD, HE CALLED IT A
SERIAL FASHION.
HE SAID HE CORRECTED THE THEN
PRESIDENT IN A SERIAL FASHION
WHEN DONALD TRUMP WOULD SAY,
ALLEGATION X, HE WOULD PUSH BACK
WITH FACTS THAT HE HAD THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT LOOK INTO.
ALLEGATION Y, SAME THING.
AND HE WOULD GO ON AND ON AND
ON, TO THE POINT WHERE DONAHUE
SAID, MR. PRESIDENT, HE SAID HE
WANTED TO CUT THROUGH THE NOISE.
HE WAS VERY INTENTIONAL, KNOWING
THAT THE PRESIDENT WAS -- HIS
BRAIN WAS BEING FILLED WITH
THESE CONSPIRACIES.
CLEARLY, HE WAS LOOKING FOR THE
CONSPIRACIES.
HE COULD NOT GET THROUGH TO HIM.
>> THE OTHER THING THAT WAS VERY
COMPELLING IS HOW THEY PUSHED
BACK ON JEFFREY CLARK, IN NO
UNCERTAIN TERMS.
HIRSHMAN SAYING,
CONGRATULATIONS, YOU JUST
ADMITTED YOUR FIRST STEP.
YOU WOULD BE COMMITTING A
FELONY.
TALKED ABOUT HOW THEY WERE
CLOBBERING HIM OVER THE HEAD.
YOU'RE AN ENVIRONMENTAL LAWYER,
HOW ABOUT YOU GO BACK TO YOUR
OFFICE AND WE'LL CALL YOU WHEN
THERE'S AN OIL SPILL.
OVER AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
AND YET DONALD TRUMP WANTED TO
PUT THIS MAN AT THE TOP OF DOJ,
JUST TO OVERTURN THE ELECTION.
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS VERY
NOTABLE, THEY MADE IT VERY
CLEAR, THERE WAS NO REASON FOR
TRUMP TO HAVE KNOWN WHO JEFFREY
CLARK WAS.
THERE WAS NO BUSINESS BEFORE THE
WHITE HOUSE THAT CLARK WOULD
HAVE BEEN AUTHORIZED TO TALK TO
TRUMP ABOUT.
THEY WERE CONFUSED AS TO WHY
JEFFREY CLARK'S NAME EVEN CAME
OUT OF TRUMP'S MOUTH ON THE VERY
FIRST DAY THAT THE ACTING
ATTORNEY GENERAL, JEFFREY ROSEN,
TOOK ON HIS JOB AND TRUMP CALLED
HIM ON THE PHONE, AS HE DID
APPARENTLY EVERY DAY FOR QUITE
SOME TIME IN THE PERIOD OF
DECEMBER AND JANUARY, AND
MENTIONED JEFF CLARK.
SO THIS IS SOMEONE TWO CAME MORE
OR LESS OUT OF OBSCURITY, BUT WE
GOT SOME IMPORTANT HINTS AS TO
HOW JEFF CLARK WAS INJECTED INTO
THE BLOOD STREAM OF THIS
CONSPIRACY.
THE NEXT DAY AFTER THAT MEETING,
SCOTT PERRY, THE CONGRESSMAN WHO
IS ALLEGEDLY SOUGHT A PARDON,
SHOWS UP BACK AT THE WHITE
HOUSE, AND BRINGS JEFFREY CLARK
BACK IN TOW.
HE WAS THERE FOR THE ONLY
PURPOSE TO BASICALLY SAY THAT
THERE WAS CORRUPTION THAT
HAPPENED, ALLOWING THE
PARTISANS, THE CORRUPT
PARTISANS
BY THE WAY, TO CARRY OUT EFFORTS
TO OVERTURN THE ELECTION IN
MULTIPLE STATES WITH NO
EVIDENCE.
>> IT'S STUNNING THAT MR. CLARK
REPEATEDLY IGNORED HIS SUPERIORS
TO STOP, TO BACK DOWN, BECAUSE
HE THOUGHT HE WAS WORKING FOR
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
THEY'RE LEADING US DOWN THE PATH
TO GET MORE INTO THE ROLE OF
MARK MEADOWS AND CONGRESSMAN
PERRY, THAT THEY HAD A SHELL
OPERATION, AND TRUMP LAND ALWAYS
SMEARS PEOPLE WHO COME OUT AND
SAY THESE THINGS.
JEFF ROSEN, AN OUTSTANDING
PURPOSE, THAT'S DONALD TRUMP,
WHO BECAME ATTORNEY GENERAL.
RICHARD DONAHUE WILL BE TAKING
OVER THE DUTIES OF DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
THANK YOU ALL.
>> AND ANDERSON, ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT IS REALLY SO
SHOCKING ABOUT THIS, IS THAT I
THINK IT WAS FORMER ACTING
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL RICHARD
DONAHUE, TELLING JEFFREY CLARK,
TELLING THIS FREELANCING,
WOULD-BE ATTORNEY GENERAL THAT
HE WAS MEDDLING IN AN ELECTION,
THAT HE WAS COMMITTING CRIMES,
THAT HE WAS BREAKING THE LAW,
AND CLARK KEPT DOING IT,
ANDERSON.
>> AND DONAHUE HIMSELF BEING
TOLD BY THE PRESIDENT, IN A
LATE-NIGHT PHONE CALL, JUST SAY
IT WAS CORRUPT AND LEAVE THE
REST TO ME AND THE REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN.
EVAN, WE JUST HEARD FROM THREE
OF THESE FORMER TOP DOJ
OFFICIALS.
WHAT ARE YOUR BIG TAKEAWAYS?
>> ONE OF THE THINGS THAT HANGS
OVER ALL OF THIS IS WHETHER
THESE MEN EVER HEARD DONALD
TRUMP ORDER THEM TO BREAK THE
LAW, TO DO SOMETHING ILLEGAL.
I THINK WHAT I'M TOLD IS NEITHER
OF THESE MEN BELIEVE THAT TRUMP
EVER ORDERED THEM TO BREAK THE
LAW.
AND THAT'S AN IMPORTANT THING,
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT CONCLUSION
AT LEAST OR ASSESSMENT FROM
THESE MEN, WHO ARE VERY
IMPORTANT WITNESSES TO A KEY
PART OF THIS ATTEMPT BY THE
FORMER PRESIDENT TO OVERTURN THE
ELECTION.
AT LEAST IN THEIR VIEW, THEIR
VIEW IS THAT HE WAS GETTING BAD
ADVICE FROM PEOPLE LIKE RUDY
GIULIANI, LIKE JOHN EASTMAN,
OTHERS WHO WERE ESSENTIALLY
PUSHING FORWARD THE IDEA THAT HE
SHOULD FIND SOME LEGAL WAY, SOME
WAY TO OVERTURN THE RESULTS OF
THE ELECTION.
AND IN THAT WAY, KEEP HIMSELF IN
POWER.
AND THAT'S THE WAY THEY VIEW
THIS.
SO ONE OF THE INTERESTING THIN